hello we're glad you joined us for this
live webinar the importance of
procalcitonin for antimicrobial
stewardship in patients with lower
respiratory tract infections in the
emergency department i am michelle aston
elaborate and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lat root a leading
scientific social networking website and
provide our virtual event a webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by bio URI
near you
world leader in the field of in vitro
diagnostics for over 55 years bile near
you is present in 43 countries and
serving more than 150 countries with the
support of a large network of
distributors pioneer you provides
diagnostic solutions systems reagents
software and services which determine
the source of disease in contamination
to improve patient health and ensure
consumer safety its products are mainly
used 5 for diagnosing infectious
diseases and some critical illnesses the
company's diagnostic solutions are also
used for detecting microorganisms and
agri-food pharmaceutical and cosmetic
products to learn more please visit
biome are you calm so let's get started
questions to the speaker during
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind to do so simply type them into the
drop-down box located on the far left of
your screen labeled ask a question and
click on the send button
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the arrows at the top right
hand corner of the presentation window
if you experience technical problems
seeing or hearing the presentation just
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problems by typing it into
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
webinar and best offers free continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit
I now present today's Speaker John bore
Rico the co-director of antimicrobial
stewardship program and a critical
affect infectious diseases pharmacists
at Duke Regional Hospital in Durham
North Carolina
he received his doctorate of pharmacy at
the University of North Carolina at
Chapel Hill and has a board-certified
infectious disease pharmacists
she has been utilizing biomarkers and
diagnostics for almost 10 years and
spearheaded the implantation and
education at his hospital
dr. burrito will now begin his
presentation
good morning and thank you Michelle also
thank you to be a mere you for
sponsoring this webinar and for their
constant dedication to improving
antibiotic stewardship worldwide as
Michelle said we're going to talk about
the importance of procalcitonin for
antibiotic stewardship mainly in
patients with lower respiratory tract
infections in the emergency department
my disclosure I do receive honoraria and
a consulting fee from Beamer you ink for
advisory and consultation
our objectives were going to gain a
better understanding of how
procalcitonin can aid in the diagnosis
of lower respiratory tract infections we
will also try to understand how
procalcitonin may aid the emergency room
clinician in deciding whether to
initiate anima cordial therapy so again
we will explore how using a
procalcitonin driven protocol in the
emergency room can aid the clinician in
deciding whether to initiate
antimicrobial therapy we're also going
to look at the existing data mainly from
a safety aspect and from decreasing
antibiotic use without adverse reactions
using a procalcitonin in patients with
presumed LRT eyes and how antibiotic
stewardship programs can use this
biomarker in shaping their clinical
decisions and lastly we will try to
examine which stewardship metrics may be
impacted by using a procalcitonin guided
protocol so my practice is at Duke
Regional Hospital
we are 369 bed Community Hospital but
we're also an academic teaching hospital
affiliated with the Duke University
Health System our emergency room is
quite busy we had in 2018 almost 70,000
visits and we are about six months into
a significant expansion of both our
emergency room and psychiatric services
so those numbers will obviously go up
let's start with a patient case and an
antibiotic question so we have a 50 year
old female who presents with increasing
speed of production and shortness of
breath her vital signs are basically
within normal limits her calculated
curve 65 score is zero her past medical
history significant for hypertension
type 2 diabetes which is diet control
COPD and osteoarthritis her social
history four to five glasses of wine per
week in a 20 pack year history of
smoking current medications with center
pearl 20 milligrams daily PRN motoring
for her osteoarthritis and a PRN
albuterol inhaler she was given a stat
albuterol nebulizer treatment at 125
milligrams of methylprednisolone in the
emergency room her chest x-ray reveals a
mildly hyper-inflated one with no
discernible infiltrates she's placed on
2 liters of oxygen via nasal cannula her
measured procalcitonin which was ordered
stat resulted in a value of less than
0.1 nanograms per mil sputum sample
obtained and sent to the lab for Gram
stain and culture and since the patient
was not be compensated we did not obtain
blood cultures so would you initiate
ceftriaxone azithromycin for presumed
cap would you initiate moxifloxacin for
a presumed respiratory infection which
you initiate azithromycin for an acute
exacerbation of COPD or would you
recommend no antimicrobial therapy and
at the end of the presentation we will
circle back to this
so TDC in 2012 look at the burden of
antibiotic use in emergency rooms
outpatient clinics and physician offices
and the good news is 70 percent of the
prescriptions were necessary but when
they did a sub analysis right drug at
the right dose for the appropriate
length of therapy was lacking 30 percent
were unnecessary prescriptions and their
goal by 2020 is to reduce inappropriate
antibiotic and used by 50 percent the
burden of antibiotic use in the hospital
setting is not much better in this
country the CDC estimates that two
million patients will acquire an
infection while hospitalized resulting
in ninety thousand deaths worldwide it's
not much better with an estimate of up
to 700 thousand deaths from a
hospital-acquired multi drug resistant
organism and studies have shown that 20
to 50 percent of antibiotics prescribed
in u.s. acute care hospitals are
unnecessary or inappropriate
hopefully this slide shows up a little
bit better but this is a CDC look at E
coli resistance in the United States in
1999 they started collecting this data
the Green Line is amino penicillins
which would be your amoxicillin in your
augment ins of the world and you can see
that as of 1999 they were almost
basically resistant whenever you exceed
that 20% threshold
antibiotic resistance is understood
quinolones
are the pink line and by 2004 we were
already approaching that 20% resistance
and we peaked into that are twenty
twelve at almost 35 percent the course
this didn't help in 1995 the FDA
approved using cipro in poultry and farm
animals to reduce infection
so that does not help as far as breeding
drug-resistant mutations that can
possibly be transmitted to humans
luckily in June 2015 the Joint
Commission on the accreditation of
healthcare organizations developed
antibiotic stewardship standards with an
implementation of January 1st of 2017
so that might account for plateauing of
drug resistance around 2012 so well
hopefully we will continue on that quest
so let's examine procalcitonin
we know what you produced some see cells
of the thyroid gland it produces in the
presence of the bacterial infection
procalcitonin is uploaded by exposure to
endotoxins and cytotoxins we know that
concentration is greater than 0.25
milligrams per mil encourage antibiotic
use and that studies have shown levels
greater than 2 min agree amil
significantly increases risk of
mortality bacterial infections again
secrete interleukins TNF alpha which
upload procalcitonin production whereas
a viral illness would have gamma
interferon secretion which actually
suppresses procalcitonin
let's look at procalcitonin against
other biomarkers we already talked about
tnf-alpha and the various interleukins
they do peak very quickly in the
presence of the bacterial infection but
then come down very quickly so if you're
patient failed to present to the
emergency room in a timely fashion he or
she may have already peaked and then the
decrease may have been may have started
CRP and the light blue line starts
peaking at around 6 hours and then goes
for about 18 to 30 hours before plateaus
out procalcitonin and the yellow line
starts to peak around 2 hours from the
bacterial insult and then over the next
24 hours will increase to its maximum
level and then because of the half-life
of 24 hours you would expect with
appropriate antibiotic therapy and
identification of the source of
infection that the procalcitonin should
start it's the climb towards 48 hours
another slide for understanding
procalcitonin kinetics again it usually
rises and we're from three to six hours
after a bacterial infection it's not
consistent in every patient so your
patient may present immediately to the
emergency room but may be slow to
respond to the bacterial insult in that
case if your initial procalcitonin was
negative
but you have a clear clinical suspicion
that he he or she may have a bacterial
infection then you can certainly repeat
procalcitonin within four to six hours
and see if they do have that increase
that you would have expected again it
Peaks usually between 12 and 24 hours
with a half-life of about 24 hours
procalcitonin production and serum
concentrations will decrease by 50% per
day with appropriate antibiotic
treatment if your second procalcitonin
level does not decrease by 50% or if it
remains the same or increases then you
have to double check your antimicrobial
regimen and make sure it's appropriate
or maybe so search for a different
source of infection that you may be
missing and if antibiotic therapy is
inadequate again procalcitonin levels
will remain high
so procalcitonin effective in
stewardship teams we know that we're
asking clinicians to either withholding
of I addicts or to stop antibiotics
early and of course their chief concern
is going to be a disc going to result in
adverse outcomes for my patient luckily
at our hospital stewardship has been
going for almost ten years
so our physician staff trusted
antibiotic stewardship and realize that
when you decrease antibiotic exposure
there are better patient outcomes
so dr. dr. shoots and company did a
meta-analysis it was vesicle basically
an update of a 2012 Cochrane review
which was to look at the safety of a
procalcitonin guided for antibiotic
stewardship their objective was to
assess the safety and efficacy of using
procalcitonin for either starting or
stopping antibiotics over a large range
of patients with varying severity zuv
acute respiratory infections and from a
from different clinical settings so his
was a randomized trial you've either got
that controlled which was standard of
care without a procalcitonin guided
regimen or the intervention group which
was procalcitonin guided antibiotic
treatment primary outcome was all cause
mortality also of treatment failure at
30 days his secondary outcomes were
antibiotic use antibiotic related side
effects and length of stay
so his results were significant from a
statistical standpoint he showed a 30%
reduction in mean time on antibiotics
and the procalcitonin guided group
and that great quality of evidence was
very high
she also looked at 30-day mortality
which was the other primary outcome and
there was a decrease in the
procalcitonin group that was also a
great quality evidence of high as far as
the secondary outcomes there was a again
a two point four day decrease in
antibiotic exposure with a quality of
evidence high and the risk of antibiotic
antibiotic antibiotic adverse drug
effects was quality of evidence moderate
length of stay and ICU were similar so
the summary of doctor shoots is Cochrane
review was that our procalcitonin guided
protocol does decrease antibiotic
exposure does decrease antibiotic
associated adverse reactions without
increasing mortality across all settings
and all types of acute respiratory
infections
dr. Boyles from Arkansas he also did a
single Center test again very similar to
dr. shoots it was a single Center
retrospective cohort he had over 2100
patients
he took patients from all settings so
critical care and acute care and he did
a pre in a post though he took data from
four years prior to procalcitonin
implementation and then he had a washout
period and then he took data from four
years after a procalcitonin
implementation his primary endpoint was
median days of therapy his secondary
endpoints were pretty vast hospital
mortality 30-day readmission cost radium
difficile infection and adverse drug
events during hospitalization
he showed a statistically significant
reduction in days of therapy when you
follow the procalcitonin protocol
for secondary outcomes 30-day and
antibiotic associated adverse drug
effects a 50% reduction a reduction in
hospital mortality and a reduction in C
difficile infection
so we have more studies that are more
contemporary one of the knocks on coal
calcitonin was that all the initial
studies were done in Europe and Asia and
not necessarily in America but with dr.
Royal study that sort of paved the way
for other other studies that are
occurring in the United States
so dr. Jennifer Townsend out of Hopkins
she did a great study it was a single
Center controlled
pre and post interventional study and
patients admitted with them LRT eyes she
had 374 patients 174 in the
procalcitonin or intervention group and
200 in the control group which was as
usual care
for a primary outcome with median
antibiotic duration and her results were
a one-day decrease in antibiotic
duration now I applaud dr. Townsend
because when you look at her inclusion
criteria
she took pneumonia patients and COPD
patients this was not a little acuity
group her pneumonia patients 47% of them
had a curb 65 of two or greater and her
COPD patients forty-one percent were
graded at theaters severe or very severe
so this was a moderate to high acuity
patient population and she still showed
a one-day decrease in antibiotic
consumption most importantly she
involved an antibiotic stewardship team
along with the procalcitonin level to
drive this study antibiotic adverse drug
events there was no difference and she
had a robust adherence of about 70% dr.
Angela branch out of Rochester she did a
open-label randomized clinical trial it
was a one-to-one randomization
and interestingly enough she compared
procalcitonin plus a viral pcr compared
it to standard of care her primary
outcome was antibiotic exposure and then
also safety at 30 and 90 days she had
300 patients 151 in the intervention or
procalcitonin group and 149 in the
control or the usual care she did have
some cap patients but they were very
small in number they did exclude anybody
with a positive infiltrate and she
showed a decrease in antibiotic
consumption by two full days this was a
study driven event so there was no
antibiotic stewardship involved again
she showed no difference in antibiotic
adverse drug events and her adherence
was 64 percent now it did differ a
little bit of this particular study with
dr. Branton and colleagues they really
favored a lower acuity level where the
adherence was a little better and that
decrease in days of therapy was more the
higher the procalcitonin and the greater
the acuity I think they were closer to
decreasing antibiotic consumption by one
day
and lastly we have the proact trial that
was dr. Aurora Wang and colleagues this
was a trial that sort of made
stewardship team sit back and say wow
because this was the first test in over
a decade
that showed that there was no difference
in decreased use of antibiotics using a
procalcitonin protocol so they had
sixteen hundred and fifty six patients
eight twenty six in the procalcitonin
group eight hundred and thirty in the
standard of care majority of their
patients were full acuity LRT I so
exacerbations of asthma and bronchitis
and again they showed no decrease in
days of therapy of antibiotics they did
not have an antibiotic stewardship team
involved a matter of fact the 14
universities that were a part of the
study did not use procalcitonin as part
of their usual care so there was no
difference in antibiotic adverse drug
reactions there were hearings up for
their cat patients were 39% and for
their non cap patients 65%
this proact trial actually reinforced my
belief from procalcitonin because it's
not just the number you can't just give
a number to a physician and say this is
it
I want you to stop antibiotics I want
you to withhold antibiotics
procalcitonin when it's paired with an
antibiotic stewardship team and
physician Trust is a valuable tool in
deciding whether or not to initiate or
discontinued antibiotics
so there are some other biomarkers of
infection we mentioned in a previous
slide CRP it is an inflammatory
biomarker including the respiratory
tract but unfortunately there's many
other disease states that will also
cause an elevation in CRP it's
associated with reduced innovative
prescribing for respiratory infections
and that was at a 2013 meta-analysis the
issue is it has very high sensitivity
but only what the levels greater than 6
mix per liter and unfortunately it does
not differentiate between bacterial
infection and viral illness and it is
unspecific but again we really don't use
it too much in respiratory infections at
this time
you
so at our Hospital there are obviously
procalcitonin limitations we know the
limitations include end-stage renal
disease renal cell carcinoma thyroid
cancers and severe burns and trauma but
we actually know that there are some
relative limitations that patients with
CKD 3 and ckb for and also patients with
Aki and non-small-cell lung cancer with
or without lobectomy may also have an
elevated procalcitonin in the absence of
an infection
we actually did a one-year study it was
part of a project of one of our um
pharmacy residents dr. Andrew Darko and
he did a great job and he did see that
in CKD 3 and CKD for patients that there
wasn't elevation and procalcitonin
levels now this is a great segue into
what stewardship teams probably need to
do they need to map ignore and stage
renal disease or CKD patients and maybe
start getting procow levels so they can
get a baseline there is anecdotal
information out there that an end-stage
renal disease patient that's not
infected as a baseline Pro Cal zero
point five nanograms per mil what is
sort of a moot point because when you're
in stage renal patient comes into your
emergency room with fevers they have a
dialysis catheter guess what we're going
to get Bank zosyn doesn't matter
Pro Cal may allow you to de-escalate
quicker but you have to preserve the
dialysis catheter at all costs but based
on dr. Darko's research we did educate
our physicians that yes we can use pro
Cal and CKD 3 and c KD 4 but we're going
to use that as part of our assessment
so just a frame procalcitonin at Duke
Regional Hospital well we use it at our
hospital in the emergency room as the
test of exclusion in patients with
presumed el RTI we also use it as a
baseline value in patients with presumed
sepsis and in our ICU settings or
internal medicine patients we will use
it as a guide to de-escalate antibiotics
and culture-negative patients so you
come in you have an acute exacerbation
of an LRT I we will get one
procalcitonin level and if that's
negative and then combine that with
clinical decision making of the
physician we will decide whether or not
we're going to admit or send home and
whether or not we're going to give
antibiotics or not you know biotics
again in the emergency room where
everything starts if that patient is
septic we will get a baseline and use
that and then we will order subsequent
procalcitonin Sunday to entry to make
sure that we're getting that 50%
reduction and we know that on day three
if the procow is 80% of what it was on
day one in a culture negative patient
you could decide to maybe start to
de-escalate antibiotics
you
so I had to justify kokal before we even
had it in our Hospital so management
wanted me to look at all of these
exacerbations of LRT eyes so what we did
was we did a back then an icd-9 code and
we looked at everything for exacerbation
of asthma bronchitis or COPD and when we
excluded our patients included not
admitted
we had 710 patients 497 received
antibiotics 77 did not you can make the
argument that says 77 patients who
didn't getting antibiotics or as sick as
the ones who did but I can make the
argument that because they have an
exacerbation of an LRT I that it's just
part of our culture that we have to give
antibiotics
so our methods of our antibiotic use
versus no antibiotic use so we already
had those two cohorts our primary
outcome was length of stay our secondary
outcome was 30 and 60 day saying cause
readmission or C diff infections or a c
diff infection that was
obtained within our Hospital
and we showed a 1.4 reduction in the
length of stay between the antibiotic
group and then note and have I had a
group
and
same time doctor musher and group in the
New England Journal of Medicine released
his findings on the tap guidelines and
for the first time ever procalcitonin
was included in all aspects of cap
basically whether or not you include
antibiotics based on the procalcitonin
level or whether you withhold based on a
pro calcitonin level and that was that
about the time when the Vita's brahms
procalcitonin got the FDA approval for
both beating in the diagnosis of lr t
eyes and also for de-escalation and
severe sepsis
so Duke regional procalcitonin
implementation we are basically using
the same algorithm that most hospitals
in this country are doing we set this
card up in our emergency room and again
if you look at a logarithm number one if
your pro Cal is less than 0.1
antibiotics are strongly discouraged if
it's 0.1 the point two for antibiotics
are discouraged if it's greater than
0.25 but less than 0.5 antibiotics are
encouraged and if it's greater than 0.5
it's like definitely start antibiotic
therapy
and this is our logarithm for severe
sepsis that just there for your
edification again we do use it in our
severe sepsis patients and of course the
values are higher you know some of the
studies that showed no change in
mortality had unrealistic expectations
where they wanted the pro Cal to be less
than 0.1 so as you can see here that the
threshold starts at 0.25 and as far as
the escalation is much much higher than
what you would expect in El RTI patients
you
so they weren't done with me so once we
got procalcitonin into our hospital they
wanted me to do another study so we were
going to examine the role of
procalcitonin guided and reducing
antibiotic initiation versus the
standard of care and we are going to
compare 30 day readmission rates for
same cause admission
so what we did was a retrospective chart
review we just did a five-month snapshot
so our inclusion criteria was from
January to May of 2016
anybody who presented with shortness of
breath and or increase in speed of
production and you needed a
procalcitonin level that was drawn
within 24 hours and it had to be less
than 0.25 milligrams per mil we excluded
the usual age under a teen pregnancy and
prisoners we did exclude kiddie
disorders including M stage 2 KD 3 for a
ki or renal cell carcinoma we also
excluded a non small cell lung cancer
and Rebecca Mason
we collected PO calcitonin levels we
looked at the percent of patients that
received antibiotics and we looked at
30-day same cause readmission rates we
compared patients with the same cost
diagnosis codes prior to the
implementation and the percent of
patients who received antibiotics
so in the pre procalcitonin cohort we
have 574 patients 87% received
antibiotics a 30-day same cause
readmission was 5.2 percent in the
procalcitonin cohort and it was 470 so
fairly robust for just a 5 5 month
snapshot 53% received antibiotics and
our 30-day same cause readmission 10.4%
so our conclusion a use of a
procalcitonin guided protocol resulted
in a 34 percent decrease in antibiotic
initiation and use of a procalcitonin
guided protocol resulted in a 93%
reduction for same cause readmissions
now this was fairly early into our
procalcitonin era my guess is if I
repeated the same exact study that I
would hope that that 34 percent decrease
in antibiotics would be higher maybe 50
to 60 percent as far as 93 percent
reduction for same cause readmissions of
I don't have an explanation for that the
only difference between the two groups
was receiving antibiotics I would not
expect to have 93 percent reduction
again but I think if you told your
c-suite that you can reduce same cause
readmission by 50 percent it would be
quite happy so we do have a pending we
do have a pending study or releases
under IRB evaluation right now hopefully
we will get IRB approval by end of July
and start collecting data September 1st
we're basically any patient presenting
to the emergency room for an acute
shortness of breath who have an order
procalcitonin level we're going to
measure adherence to the pro calcitonin
guided protocol we're going to stratify
procalcitonin values and compare the
percentage of antibiotic prescriptions
so basically we're going to look at the
four different boxed categories of
procow and see at which point
antibiotics were prescribed more often
in other words higher acuity levels
we're going to assess the accuracy of
procalcitonin so we always measure it
against what we grow and we'll assess
30-day same cause readmission rates
between each cohort
so implementation pearls you've got to
include all aspects of our emergency
room in this decision you need to talk
to the emergency room doctors and the
nurse practitioners and physicians
assistants you need to talk to the CMO
they need to be totally absolutely
involved in this protocol you need to
educate you need to continue to educate
all the time when we started it in our
emergency room I was there two or three
times a day looking at the log looking
at the different meeting diagnoses and
recommending procalcitonin levels in
these patients we reinforced the
protocol in person and easily findable
information cards we had a continued
presence for the first month or two and
we made sure that our emergency room
pharmacist was well disciplined and
educated as far as the use of
procalcitonin you've got to give your
emergency room the data so they can see
the potential that procalcitonin may
have for their patients in their
Department and procalcitonin absolutely
has to be actionable that means it can't
just sit in a computer database and the
clinician not be able to see it so
that's a big decision for your hospital
are you going to put it in the chemistry
lab are you going to put it in the
microwave we chose the chemistry lab
because it was a 24/7 facility if your
hospitals micro lab turns the lights off
at 11 o'clock and doesn't turn them on
again until 7:00 a.m. then you probably
want to put that procalcitonin device in
the chemistry lab we also run our pro
calcitonin off the chemistry tubes
anyway so when we emergency room draws a
tube of blood it goes to the chemistry
lab they do their thing and then they
transfer it to the co calcitonin machine
and then they get that level if for some
reason you choose to do the
procalcitonin or a micro lab there's
going to be a good communication pathway
between the chemistry lab which is going
to get that blood tube first and then
transfer to the micro lab
but it absolutely has to be actionable
we have embedded in our computer system
of the interpretive analysis of that
procalcitonin value so the position
doesn't have to go look for the placard
to see what 0.23 means versus less than
0.1 so that value is right on the screen
and begin you have to educate and
continue to educate it's very important
to choose the correct role calcitonin
again we use it mainly as a test of
exclusion in the emergency room we're up
on the floors so we do use the Vitis
brahms procalcitonin which one was the
only test use for all the studies over
the last 10 or 12 years it's the only
study that FDA approved for this
indication and it's very sensitive at
very low levels one of the competitors
unfortunately does not have sensitivity
until 0.16 nanogram per mil in our
hospital for a test of exclusion that
would eliminate at least 85% of my use
for that value so we're very happy with
the Vitis Brahms Pro Cal because we
trust the fact that it gives us a
sensitive reading for the el RTI
patients
potential barriers merge your own
physician they only have one exposure
with the patient right so is there a
policy in place at your institution
where your emergency room clinician can
follow up on this decision either to
admit or not admit or give antibiotics
or not give antibiotics it's difficult
physicians and mid-level practitioners
are very busy so you know that they have
the ability to see the outcomes of their
decisions so that's one of the barriers
for implementation and of course we have
the regulatory restrictions that impact
decisions to follow a pro calcitonin
protocol we know for sepsis we have to
give the antibiotics within three hours
of recognizing sepsis obviously we're
not going to wait for the pro Cal if
your patient is in septic shock you're
going to get antibiotics and they're
going to get it within one hour but we
know we have to meet that three hour
requirement and hospitals are penalized
by CMS by withholding some payments if
we exceed a readmission threshold for
COPD so obviously that is an issue
most of metrics I wish it was easy but
it's not it's continuously changing it's
very fluid
we love to decrease pharmacy
expenditures for antibiotics we know
from all the studies that we can reduce
the antibiotics between 30 and 50
percent if you're using less antibiotics
that's less checks you have to write but
you know what does the drug shortage is
now a lot of times we have to purchase
antibiotics at much higher cost and with
some of the newer agents we're talking a
hundred two with $1,200 a day so
expenditures if we lessen them are nice
but there's too many compounders and we
really don't look at that the c-suite
does but as clinicians we are only
interested in outcomes we want to
decrease antibiotic consumption we know
that daily defined doses is a losing
favor and that we are looking at days of
therapy you have to make sure you're
calculating days of therapy correctly
otherwise you're going to have an
inflated days of therapy for certain
antibiotics decrease length of stay is
good but there's too many compounders we
can get you off antibiotics but if
you're having trouble with your blood
sugar you're still going to be stuck in
the hospital and you know one of the
things as far as decrease like this day
is we now have thankfully some robust
studies that show that shorter courses
of antibiotics are just as effective
with less negative outcomes for disease
states like UTIs intra-abdominal skin
--skin structure and LRT is you may see
some people that say well that
procalcitonin did not cause us to use
less antibiotics it was the new studies
but antibiotic stewardship is a village
and it takes a village so you need all
these robust high evidence studies that
prove that we can use shorter courses of
antibiotics parlayed with procalcitonin
which is the trust factor in knowing
that you can
the antibiotics work at mortality is
always a dicey issue again with all the
compounders we can get our ICU patient
off antibiotics and off the ventilator
but if they're severely decompensated
we're just it's going to be very
difficult to change that mortality but
if we do look at mortality we really
have to just use same cause or same
diagnosis and not all cause mortality
and of course readmission rates that
that's probably the most important
parameter that we use at our Hospital if
we can prove that using shorter courses
of antibiotics and decreasing length of
stay results in no increase in
readmission rates then it's a win-win
and lastly for stewardship how do we
define as its relation if your patient
comes in with an acute exacerbation of
COPD they're going to get five days
they're going to get the infamous deepak
well it was that as if through Meissen
antibiotic or was it an
anti-inflammatory and when you're
collecting your data you need to make
that decision because otherwise you're
going to have a false elevation of
antibiotic consumption we know that from
resistance that zip through Meissen is
about 30 percent resistant against strep
pneumo in the entire country with a
range of 25 to 45 percent basically
ineffective against the usual pathogens
that will cause it you know truly cause
of bacterial el RTI so if we're using as
if through my son as an immuno modulator
or as an anti-inflammatory agent we know
that it has some data we know that the
data supports that you will increase the
time between acute exacerbations but at
what cost
right we're using sub-therapeutic
concentrations of the drug 250
milligrams Monday Wednesday and Friday
which unfortunately is going to breed
more resistance because whenever you use
small doses the drug getting back to
that CDC thing you know you're going to
breed resistance
here and of course for long-term is that
through Meissen you have to have hearing
checks and you have to be treated or
tested at least twice yearly for non
tuberculosis micro bacterium
so thank you very much in I will pass
this on to Michelle our moderator and be
glad to answer anybody's questions
thank you dr. burrito for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window label to ask a
question and click on the send button we
will answer as many questions as time
permits all right the first question is
would you withhold antibiotics on an LRT
i patient presenting to the IDI until
your until you receive the initial PCT
results okay that's actually a great
question and it depends on the patient
and it depends on your ER staff at our
institution if you come in and you have
an LRT I but you don't know if it's cap
the position may order ceftriaxone
azithro but if the chest x-ray comes
back you know not clearly defining and
infiltrate we will recommend waiting for
the procalcitonin before actually
initiating the antibiotics and in our
institution if we want its that we will
have those results within one hour so we
don't waiting times in our emergency
room so that's a great question and
obviously if your patients decompensated
know you're going to you're going to
give the antibiotics and X they need
them
great thank you how many PCP tests would
you typically run on a patient
presenting to the IDI with an L RTI
during the flu season you know that
that's interesting question we normally
just get one because if your chest x-ray
is without infiltrate in your
procalcitonin is negative and if your
PCR influenza is positive for a or B
we're just going to recommend treating
for influenza you know if your chest
x-ray is a little spotty we may order a
repeat procalcitonin for the following
day just to make sure we don't have a
developing bacterial pneumonia right
thank you all right this is a two-part
question so regarding the graph of the
various biomarkers does this illustrate
a single exposure to bacterial infection
and the respective time course and if
the bacterial infection is ongoing do
these biomarkers remain at the elevated
level okay that's another good question
that is just a single exposure to the
bacteria we know with that single
exposure we get the cytokine and
endotoxin response which will stimulate
full calcitonin production we also know
that if we don't initiate antibiotics at
that procalcitonin will continue with
climb CRP may continue a climb but we
don't we can't differentiate between
viral illness and a bacterial infection
and obviously we need to make sure we
have the correct antibiotics on board so
if you don't have the correct
antibiotics on board or you miss a site
of infection that procalcitonin should
continue to increase
great thank you all right your next
question is what level of procalcitonin
do we expect in viral and bacterial
infection can it be elevated
the only time we would see it elevated
is if the patient had some sort of renal
disease or one disease other than that
we've never seen an elevated
procalcitonin in a viral illness
okay your next question is does it have
a role in Mycobacterium tuberculosis
infection
at this point it does not there's
ongoing studies to see if the
availability of it would potentially
help you do that
again we only get NPM testing and those
who are on long-term immunosuppression
or zip through Meissen therapy
thank you would there not also be an
opportunity to personalize the
escalation in culture positive patient
or even identify when the PCT is not
decreasing
despite antimicrobial management and
support additional reassessment of the
source control
you know there would any antibiotic
stewardship team can personalize this
once in a critically ill patient once we
grow an organism we tend not to get
another procalcitonin only because if
you have appropriate therapy if your
patient has club bacteremia and their
procalcitonin is 13 we put them on two
grams of ceftriaxone the next day they
differ best quickly we don't even bother
with surveillance cultures to see if
they clear their bloodstream program-
because that patient is already
different vest they're doing fine if for
some reason they compensate a couple
days later even though we have
identification of the organisms
sensitivities and m.i.c patterns you
know then it's almost the onus is on the
clinician to rescan or reimage to see if
we're missing a source of infection
great thank you what was the l OS data
on in patients with pneumonia on ppl
monitored patients and those who did not
have the PTL used
I'm trying to wrap my head around this
question so I guess they're asking
patients with pneumonia
you
the only thing we can do is again there
are two different cohorts and if we did
not utilize a pro Cal protocol then we
would compare that with the cohort that
we did use the protocol in and then you
can compare the length of stay again you
would have to normalize that length of
stay and get rid of any confounders that
may have falsely increased your length
of stay based on one or two or three
other comorbidities
thank you all right your next question
is is PCT only used for El RTI or other
types of infections oh well we do use it
for respiratory we know it's highly
effective in what stream infections and
a lot of times those bloodstream
infections are incidental finding you
come in for presume pneumonia or even a
UTI and then all of a sudden you're Pro
Calais sky-high and sure enough you have
a bacterial infection so we definitely
use it we've seen it also very positive
for c diff infections the only thing we
really don't see it being elevated is
with UTIs there's some anecdotal
information out there that even in the
absence of bacteremia that propel may be
elevated in the UTI but we need to get
more data before we look at that
thank you how would you schedule follow
up TCG testing when considering serial
CCP's that would be the illness of the
patient so if we know you're sceptic
you're not responding to antibiotics we
would definitely get a serial CRO kal so
you know if you came into our emergency
room at 4 p.m. in your pro Cal was
moderately elevated and then we put you
on broad-spectrum antibiotics we would
probably schedule a pro Cal with the
early morning labs and hopefully it
would be 50% of the first level which
means you got the right antibiotics on
board and you probably haven't missed
another source of infection if you
really are suspicious of the bacterial
infection and the initial pro Cal is
negative they just may be a slow
responder and then I would not only do a
serial but probably one in four to six
hours to see if it's gone up a little
bit
thank you all right your next question
is do you include rapid respiratory
viral panel testing in your EDL RTI
algorithm algorithm we do during
influenza season we are also
implementing hopefully this month or
next month a bio fire respiratory panel
which will help us in deciding whether
or not we have a bacterial infection or
a viral illness but you know this time a
month now we wouldn't get a viral except
if it's from the CNS for a septic viral
meningitis
you
great thank you we are receiving so many
great questions right now let's see your
next question will be
how do CRP and PCT compare and bacterial
infections I'm not sure if there's
enough data for me to answer that
question again CRP isn't specific enough
to rule in or out the bacterial
infection there's just too many
autoimmune diseases or conditions like
osteomyelitis or endocarditis that would
also cause an increase in CRP levels
we actually just use CRP as a baseline
and then as a response to therapy for
our osteomyelitis patients
great thank you all right your next
question is what was the stewardship
team's role in the study if involved was
it a 24 by 7 involvement and have you
considered utilizing bio fire combined
with PCT based stewardship
oh absolutely I mean again bio fire is
just amazing especially in the blood it
enables us to narrow therapy oh my gosh
within 18 hours instead of the
traditional 36 to 48 hours if we combine
that with the procalcitonin again the
procalcitonin is the trust it's the
safety net for all of this if your
clinical suspicion is I don't think this
patient has an infection and you get a
negative procalcitonin level that just
reinforces your decision that you can
probably win hold or immediately
deescalate antibiotics
thank you is TPT used for substance
oh absolutely yes again the initial
baseline which we obtained in the
emergency room and then we'll get this
will definitely get serial procalcitonin
levels so on day two and day three
looking for that reduction if day two is
the same or elevated then we really look
at that patient much more closely maybe
change antibiotic regimens or again
search for different sites of infection
that we're obviously missing because if
you're on broad-spectrum antibiotics and
you're kokal continues to go up no
that's an issue of something is arrived
somewhere and we need to find it
great well procalcitonin levels the
elevators for fungal infections we have
not seen that yet so we don't know we
know that fungal infections have beady
cocaine and galacto Menem as part of
their cell wall that's more of a
cholesterol based so at this point I
have not utilized procalcitonin for
fungal infections were mainly in the BD
group can collect a man and arrow for
that vial arm for that rapid diagnostic
thank you what is your lavatory
turnaround time for PCP results if we
run at status within one hour if we run
it normally it's a four hour turnaround
time so again we don't ever impact the
waiting room in the emergency room by
keeping a bit occupied by somebody
waiting for a procalcitonin level and
that's you know that's just reinforces
the fact that it's got to be actionable
if it's a send out that would be
difficult at best at least as a test of
exclusion if you can get it within 24
hours it would be helpful for your
septic patients but if you're going to
use it for a test of exclusion you need
to have that result within one or two
hours so you don't impact the waiting
room at the emergency department
great thank you
some of the reasons to see false
negatives for PCP levels we know for
some atypical bacteria mainly
Mycobacterium and chlamydia because
they're encapsulated that they tend to
not cause procalcitonin and elevate
that's not the issue with Legionella if
you have regional pneumo philia you're
going to have a markedly elevated
procalcitonin
it looks like we have time for one more
question would you recommend utilization
of PCP would be meaningful for both KP
and HIV
it's always meaningful because it's that
degree of trust that it gives you for
cat patients it helps us whether or not
it says viral cap I mean if you look at
the CDC epic trial I mean it used rather
invasive sampling mechanisms and they
only grew an organism about 38% of the
time and the vast majority of those were
viral so in capital e helps you whether
or not you need to use antibiotics or
not have a different story obviously
you've been in the hospital for four to
five days or longer you have to
anticipate that the respiratory event
going on will be hospital-acquired bugs
which is going to introduce your
drug-resistant Klebsiella you're
Pseudomonas and you're staph aureus
so procalcitonin would definitely be
beneficial because if you were growing
one of those bugs it would be markedly
elevated
I would like to once again thank dr.
burrito for his presentation do you have
any final comments for our audience
ideal I mean embrace procalcitonin it's
part of and I think it's an integral
part of antibiotic stewardship you need
to adjudicate hundreds of Pro Cal's
before you really get a good trust and
that's both infectious disease
physicians and pharmacists anyway attic
stewardship team and the clinicians the
more procalcitonin that you look at and
you see that the outcomes were better
and that there were no adverse reactions
from what holding antibiotics the more
you trust the test it's all about trust
you absolutely have to involve all the
players and once they trust the test and
it's a valuable component of any
stewardship program thank you I'd like
to thank the audience for joining us
today and for our interesting questions
any questions we did not have time for
today will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration we
would also like to thank our sponsor by
a mere you for underwriting today's
educational webcast until next time
goodbye